hey guys what's up I'm Daniel and you're
watching DLM model life style now if
you're new to my channel please
subscribe so that you won't miss
anything new and on this channel you'll
find anything has got to do with
grooming style fitness & the model
life now in this video we are gonna talk
about male model hairstyles we're gonna
look at the best hairstyles for a short
medium and long hair styles and we are
starting right now
now we are going to look at a few
pictures of models from my agency in
South Africa we're gonna look at Boss
models in Johannesburg and we're gonna
look at contact models in Cape Town
now when you look at these models focus
on how their hairstyle fits in with
their unique look if you want to book
any of these models including me check
out the video description I've added
the links so you can get in contact with
them alright let's have a look
music playing
right there are some pretty cool
hairstyles right but if you want to
change to a new hairstyle don't just
choose the hairstyle that is in right
now meaning that's very trendy why
because you'll just look the same as
everybody else choose a hairstyle that
really fits in with your unique look
now hairstyles are very important
because it tells people a lot about you
especially on first impressions when
somebody sees you for the first time
they make these assumptions they make
these assumptions based on your
appearance where they kind of think all
right this guy is very neat this guy's
very professional this one is very
laid-back this guy is very chilled and
especially in modeling those first
impressions when you go to the castings
is very important if you don't impress
the client when you go to that casting
you don't have a good chance of booking
the job and once you've got your
hairstyle you need good hair products to
style it I've added my favorite hair
styling products in the video
description down below so you can check
those out now let me know which is your
favorite hair style in the comments down
below if you liked the video give me a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video